it's still crazy to me that we are still
talking about this and I see I have so
many different friends from different
skin tones and you know a lot of girls
happen to be richer in skin tone and one
of the things they'll say is our people
will say to them is like oh your skin is
so perfect you don't need makeup but I'm
like how do you know like what if they
actually wanted to play with makeup you
know I just think not giving them the
opportunity for that is just not okay
and you see that also on their very fair
side as well there's so many journeys
within skintone where where people just
need to really start accepting you know
that we have different needs everyone
has a different need you maybe can't you
know serve everyone but you should try
your best because if you don't you're
essentially also saying that some people
are not a part of this journey which is
not something that we should be sending
if you're truly about beauty then you
know that everyone deserves it I want to
just talk to you about your daughter now
and the fact that she's she's growing up
part of a generation that they never
knew a world without social media so
when you're doing yeah right so when
you're doing your videos do you think
about the the message that you're giving
to little girls like North she's always
in the back of my head
whether it's like me you know trying to
make sure I'm not objectifying women